we're expecting the results from this
five year old boy sometime this
afternoon so we will know whether or not
he has a bulla or at least tests
positive preliminary in a few hours in
the meantime there's some news about a
health worker who does not have Ebola
the nurse kaci Hickox who was held in a
New Jersey hospital over the weekend
because she had just returned from West
Africa treating Ebola patients tested
negative for Ebola but she was held in
this hospital under a new mandatory
quarantine order from the new york and
new jersey governor's chris christie and
andrew cuomo that's right which she
objected to be objected to it she hired
a lawyer she was threatening legal
action but this morning we just got a
statement actually from the state of New
Jersey office of the governor saying she
tested negative she's leaving the
hospital and she has requested transport
to Maine so she will be leaving the
hospital she'll be quarantined as long
as she's in New Jersey but once she
leaves the state she's free to go he's
free to go so once she gets to Maine or
once she leaves essentially New Jersey's
borders what happens and well that will
be up to Maine so all the power to
quarantine and restrict travel lies with
the states I've been talking to health
law professors over the weekend they
said this is a really tricky law we
don't have experienced quarantine a well
people which these health care workers
coming back from Africa or well they're
not showing symptoms of Ebola it will at
least in the case of this nurse so it is
a tricky law to implement its state by
state and once she leaves New Jersey
[ __ ] you know it'll be a bit as a
government of Maine to decide whether or
not she should be quarantine or or if
she can go out in public like we saw the
doctor who has Ebola here craig venter
do in New York right so it's very much a
state a states rights issue okay so
mandatory quarantine rules though I mean
what are the challenges and trying to
mandate that there there are some big
big challenges when I talked to these
health law professors they said first of
all you have to figure out how you're
going to quarantine them usually it's up
to the person to stay at home and unless
they break that quarantine then you can
get police involved or then you can
force them to stay somewhere so with all
of these health workers coming back are
we going to have police monitoring them
are we going to hold them in hospitals
that's really unclear at this point
another big challenge is how will the
state's identify the workers who are
coming back when they fly into the
country the customs and borders
officials are federal officials so it
would require them to notify the state
employees about whether or not they need
to quarantine these people you it would
require compliance from federal
officials so that gets into tricky
ground too because as we saw this
weekend there was a lot of backlash from
the federal government over these
quarantines and then of course the
biggest concern we're hearing is these
new rules may deter people from going to
West Africa and the first flights a
virus and help English idea yes helping
with the effort okay a lot of unanswered
questions much more on this Shelby thank
you so much Shelby holiday of Bloomberg
News